Salut et bienvenue dans la série de cours sur l'Algorithme Variationnel Quantique des Valeurs Propres.
Je m'appelle Victoria Lipinska et dans cette vidéo, on va voir comment représenter
un problème VQE donné d'une façon que l'ordinateur quantique comprend.
En général, un problème de chimie quantique est exprimé en termes d'énergies
du système.
On appelle l'opérateur qui décrit ces énergies le Hamiltonien.
D'abord, on doit le quantifier.
C'est-à-dire l'exprimer dans le langage de la chimie quantique,
ce qu'on appelle formellement la seconde quantification.
Si le Hamiltonien décrit des interactions fermioniques, par exemple
l'énergie des électrons dans des orbitales de spin, on parle
de Hamiltonien fermionique, et ce sera notre point de départ aujourd'hui.
Les qubits, cependant, ont leur propre langage.
Les opérateurs dans le monde des qubits sont décrits par les opérateurs de Pauli.
Notre objectif ici est donc d'exprimer les opérateurs fermioniques
en termes d'opérateurs qubit.
Il existe une correspondance simple et directe entre
les états zéro et un pour les fermions et les qubits.
Donc la correspondance entre les états est aussi directe.
Cependant, la correspondance des opérateurs est un peu plus complexe.
Les Hamiltoniens fermioniques sont exprimés avec des opérateurs de création et
d'annihilation.
Notre travail consiste donc à faciliter la compréhension
du Hamiltonien par un ordinateur quantique.
On va utiliser des outils mathématiques pour convertir un Hamiltonien fermionique
en un Hamiltonien qubit avec des gates.
Autrement dit, on va traduire entre
le langage de la chimie quantique et celui de l'informatique quantique.
Imagine deux chaînes, l'une avec des fermions,
donc le langage de la chimie quantique.
Et l'autre avec des qubits, donc le langage de l'informatique quantique.
À première vue, la correspondance semble simple, non ?
Dans les deux cas, on voit des systèmes à deux niveaux.
Pour les fermions, on a soit un fermion dans l'état
soit aucun fermion du tout.
Et pour les qubits, on a soit l'état 0 soit l'état 1.
Cependant, c'est plus nuancé que ça.
La différence entre une chaîne de qubits et une chaîne de fermions
est quelque chose de très fondamental en physique : ce qu'on appelle la symétrie d'échange.
Deux fermions ne peuvent jamais occuper le même état.
Mais pour une chaîne de qubits, c'est complètement différent.
Deux qubits peuvent tous les deux être dans le même état,
car un qubit n'est pas un fermion.
On doit maintenant trouver un moyen de traduire entre les deux chaînes.
Dès 1928, deux chercheurs, Jordan et Wigner,
ont montré que les opérateurs fermioniques pour toute la chaîne
peuvent être représentés exactement en termes d'opérateurs qubit.
C'est la correspondance la plus directe pour un ordinateur quantique.
Par exemple, on peut l'utiliser pour associer l'occupation
d'une orbitale au spin d'un seul qubit.
En pratique, cette correspondance pour un Hamiltonien donne une somme pondérée d'opérateurs de Pauli.
C'est un fait très important, que j'aimerais que tu gardes en tête,
et on y reviendra dans le prochain module où on parlera
de la façon dont les circuits variationnels sont exécutés sur l'ordinateur quantique.
La correspondance ci-dessus signifie que si on avait, par exemple,
14 opérateurs fermioniques, on va projeter le problème sur 14 qubits.
Heureusement, il existe des méthodes astucieuses pour réduire le nombre de qubits
et utiliser moins de ressources quantiques pour obtenir de meilleures performances d'un ordinateur quantique.
En général, dans un système moléculaire, on connaîtra
certaines symétries physiques du Hamiltonien,
par exemple, le nombre total d'électrons est fixé.
Cette information peut être utilisée pour réduire la taille du problème
sans perdre aucune information pertinente.
On appelle cette technique la réduction de l'espace actif.
Elle permet de réduire le nombre de ressources, à savoir le nombre de qubits,
avant la correspondance qubit comme la transformation de Jordan-Wigner.
Cette étape calcule un Hamiltonien effectif
et nous permet d'utiliser moins de qubits en conséquence.
Pour notre exemple avec 14 orbitales,
cette technique réduit le nombre de qubits à seulement six.
On peut maintenant aller encore plus loin dans ces réductions.
On peut utiliser différentes correspondances,
qui sont un peu plus élaborées que Jordan-Wigner.
L'exemple le plus courant est la correspondance de parité.
La correspondance de parité ne projette pas l'occupation des orbitales sur les qubits,
mais plutôt la parité des orbitales sur des qubits individuels.
On n'entrera pas dans les détails mathématiques ici,
mais ce qu'il est important de savoir, c'est que cette correspondance contient des
redondances supplémentaires qui peuvent être exploitées pour éliminer deux qubits de plus.
Ainsi, notre exemple avec 14 orbitales passe de 14 qubits
à 6 qubits avec la réduction de l'espace actif, puis à 4 qubits
avec la réduction à deux qubits dans la correspondance de parité.
Mentionnons brièvement une transformation de plus.
Une autre correspondance couramment utilisée entre la représentation
fermionique et qubit est la transformation de Bravyi-Kitaev.
La transformation de Bravyi-Kitaev utilise des qubits pour encoder l'information
sur le nombre d'occupation et la parité de l'état quantique.
La transformation de Bravyi-Kitaev combine les informations de nombre d'occupation et de parité
pour une base d'orbitales moléculaires de taille N,
on utilise à nouveau N qubits.
Cependant, l'information stockée dans chaque qubit
varie maintenant selon le qubit concerné.
C'est-à-dire que quand l'indice du qubit est pair,
il stocke le nombre d'occupation de l'orbitale correspondante,
comme dans la correspondance de Jordan-Wigner.
Quand l'indice du qubit est impair, le qubit stocke la parité d'un ensemble particulier
de nombres d'occupation. La transformation de Bravyi-Kitaev est la plus efficace
quand le nombre de qubits s'approche d'une puissance de deux.
La correspondance de Bravyi-Kitaev combine les avantages de Jordan-Wigner
et des transformations de parité.
Elle réduit le nombre de qubits sur lesquels agit chaque terme du Hamiltonien,
ce qui est important pour la simulation quantique car les termes
agissant sur un grand nombre de qubits dans le Hamiltonien
nécessitent des circuits plus longs pour leur simulation.
Cela signifie que la profondeur du circuit
est réduite avec la transformation de Bravyi-Kitaev et qu'en général
on peut obtenir de meilleurs résultats avec le matériel.
C'est une amélioration par rapport à la transformation de Jordan-Wigner
qui donne un Hamiltonien qubit d'ordre N.
Donc, dans cette vidéo, on a exploré des méthodes pour projeter
un Hamiltonien fermionique sur un Hamiltonien qubit.
Dans la suivante, on verra comment choisir au mieux l'état
et une forme variationnelle ou un circuit.
On se retrouve là-bas.